et bien lise d'après les dernières
nouvelles que nous avons reçu des
pompiers le feu serait en train de
baisser d'intensité mais il continuerait
de progresser les pompiers disent qu'il
est sous contrôle mais pas encore éteint
alors vous l'avez dit l'incendie s'est
déclaré dans l'après-midi au sud de
Dijon sur le plateau de chenauve un feu
très important qui a provoqué vous le
voyez sans doute derrière moi un fort
dégagement de fumée d'ailleurs les
pompiers ont reçu beaucoup d'appels de
dijeunet qui signalaient le sinistre
alors c'est un feu de végétation il n'y
a aucun danger 2 haectares de résineux
sont partis en fumer d'importants moyens
évidemment ont été déployés très
rapidement sur place une cinquantaine de
pompiers des des casernes alentours sont
intervenus des pompiers soutenus par une
quinzaine de véhicules un hélicoptère a
même fait un survol de la zone avant
d'attaquer les flammes il faut être
prudent nous disait tout à l'heure les
pompiers si le feu est en train d'être
maîtrisé on l'a beaucoup dit ces
derniers jours la sécheresse et le vent
à se les flammes il faut donc rester
prudent alors il y a beaucoup
d'habitations à chenauve autour de ce
feu mais il n'y a à cette heure-ci aucun
danger aucune évacuation n'a été faite
les pompiers sécurisent les maisons les
habitations trois points sensibles ont
toutefois été identifié il s'agit du
cercle hipique de chenauve du chenil de
chenauve ainsi que le centre de
rééducation d'ivot donc voilà trois
points qui vont être surveillés avec
grande attention je vous le répète le
feu serait maîtrisé mais les pompiers
veulent à cette heure-ci rester prudents